[Musique]
chez lui le sort de paul communal
changer dix ans la soeur de paul guth
juste ou s'il tient à tanger pas les
yeux je voudrais à vannes au fond tu
n'aimes pas alors je te le demande
est ce moi et si je suis moi je te dis
non alors c'est la guerre
tu t'entends bien avec abel toi ah bah
je n'aime pas il a mal à ma mère raconte
comment elle a fait quand même du poivre
[Musique]
est ce que je t'ai pas si j'allais moins
avec elle je serai bien qu'elle tu
attires si je couche avec m est ce que
ça veut dire que je dois vivre avec elle
sa monnaie tout l'air non ça c'est ce
qu'elle nous dit prendre quelques
affaires
walker ticket
i
[Musique]
on paraît que tout le monde en jouant
vite chez taito par exemple pas déjà eu
envie de quelqu'un
oui toi
[Musique]